attorneys for Mexican drug lord Joaquin
el chapo guzman say they will appeal his
conviction a federal jury found Guzman
guilty on 10 counts yesterday including
drug trafficking and money laundering
now he is expected to be sentenced to
life without parole in June Guzman's
attorney Jeff Lichtman has defended
other high-profile clients including
American mobster John Gotti Jr he joins
us for an interview you'll see only and
first here on CBS this morning good
morning
thanks for having me we talked about
there were 14 cooperating witnesses that
the jurors heard from text messages
videos weapons an incredible amount of
evidence by the prosecution
on what grounds will you be able to make
an appeal well I mean look there were
plenty of errors during the trial our
cross examination of the co-operators
was incredibly restricted I've never had
this happen in a case where some very
basic areas we were not allowed to go
into in fact one of the witnesses
believe that the earth was about to be
destroyed in an apocalypse
he believed in 15-foot aliens roaming
the earth searching for gold and I
wasn't allowed to question him on any of
that so the jury
perhaps believed that he was saying when
in fact it was pretty clear that he was
out of his mind that was just one of
many errors in the case now I don't know
that an appeal will work because as you
said there was a tremendous amount of
evidence but you know this is what we
did we try why don't you allow him on
the jury though if that guy believed or
no he was one of the cooperating witness
after the after the trial you said
something along the lines of my client
was presumed guilty do you not think he
got a fair trial I don't think he got a
fair trial I mean look the press has to
do its job and I completely get it
but the the press was overwhelmingly
negative before the jury was even picked
we were presumed guilty it was very
difficult to get around the myth of El
Chapo in addition as I said the cross
examinations were so restricted so
restricted that I don't believe that the
jury ever really heard the full truth
about these done why didn't he take this
thing we look at it's very rare in a
criminal case where a defendant takes
the stand and they had a tremendous
amount of material to cross-examine him
how do we put him on the stand and my
belief was if we have any chance to win
the case
we'll lose it if you take the stand 30
minutes in closing comments the 30
minutes means nothing I mean I don't
know any defense lawyer who puts on very
much who are we gonna call other drug
dealers from Mexico to say that he
wasn't involved it's not the case that
we put on it was the cross-examination
of a witness as the matter so I'm
confused you said they have a tremendous
amount of material to cross-examine him
on but then you just call it a myth so
did they have a lot of material
including how he ordered murders and all
of that or was it a myth they have to
understand the fact that he was involved
in drug dealing we never denied we
claimed this he was not the kingpin that
was the charge that landed him in prison
for the rest of his life if he was
convicted so our position was he was
really a fall guy there is a guy in
Mexico who leads the Sinaloa cartel who
has been indicted in America for decades
he's been indicted in Mexico he has
never been arrested in 50 years
he pays hundreds of millions of dollars
they've been able to get him Jeff they
hadn't been able to get them you know
what you can't find who you're not that
does not make our Chapel innocent just
evolve does nothing yeah that's a fair
point obviously this is not an easy case
it doesn't make him innocent but our
position was that he was not the kingpin
and therefore did not deserve a life
sentence that the kingpin statute but
George spent six days poring through
testimony from over 50 witnesses the
judge even went out of her way and said
she felt like she was a proud American
given the dedication that these huge
crew the judge exactly he was a proud
American given the dedication that these
jurors put in what did they miss what
did they get wrong well I have to tell
you they certainly put the time in I
mean this was a case that everybody
expected when the case started the jury
would be out an hour they were out six
days six days I mean this was a jury
that very well could have come back and
either acquitted to him or hung and we
were expecting that could happen what
did they miss you know as I said the
jury missed a lot of the impeachment
material one of the witnesses one of the
cooperating witnesses was threatening
the people in the government threatening
to show all details about the witness
protection program to the Mexican
cartels who are not allowed across
examine all should
because all talk about the verdict that
they returned because a lot of people
are concerned about sitting on that jury
and you're very concerned because I know
that they be concerned now I don't think
so I mean a good guy a good guy was
gonna go after he's in complete
isolation
apparently his friends detractors are
gonna speak to he can't have any visits
other than from attorneys he can't see
his wife he can see his seven year old
daughters he's not allowed to see anyone
he is in complete isolation for two
years and this is the isolation just so
you know that one of the co-operators
said that it was torture he was tortured
by the American government and that's
what caused him to cooperate that's what
walking be cool cat Jeff and a pleasure
to represent it was you think he's a
good person
I listen being a cool cat and a player
to represent does not make him a good
person asking you do you think he was
good to me and if I as a defense lawyer
if I start being concerned with what
people are accused of and what they're
convicted of I'll never be able to get
out of bed in the morning I need to look
at them
how do you treat me because they need
the most vigorous defense and look we
all go to your cocktail parties and you
have friends that are being investigated
for tax evasion guess what I'm the one
that they call I don't know I've never
been at a cocktail party with you guys
Jeffrey Lichtman thank you thanks so
much